new york post had an article out
transgender student grant sykes i don't
know if i'm saying that last name right
or wrong i apologize grant if i'm saying
it wrong rejected from every university
of alabama sorority
here's some of the article a transgender
woman was rejected by all university of
alabama sororities during their student
recruitment process according to social
media posts from the student grant sykes
wrote on instagram that she was denied
entry to all of the sororities on campus
there are nearly 20 campus chapters
there's a long quote there and a video
uh on tick tock i'm hopeful of a future
where everyone is welcome for just being
themselves everywhere psych's continued
if you're going through a hard time
today remember that life's too short to
ponder the things lost
and in a tick-tock
psych said i'm sad because i wanted to
be part of a sisterhood
interesting and more than that a
community now if you listen to the video
can we play a little bit of that video
right there tyler
hi guys it's grant today was prep round
and i got a phone call this morning and
i was cut
it is extremely upsetting and
i'm sad because i wanted to be a part of
a sisterhood and more than that a
community
and you know it's kind of just
i keep on waiting for my rokai to call
me and be like
just kidding
you could bring it on to bid day
tomorrow because tomorrow's bed day okay
i don't even know what to say so i
watched this i also read a bunch of
content i personally do feel that this
individual is being sincere about what
she wants i'm going to say she that's a
pronoun whatever
this individual wants to be part of a
sister i believe that's a sincere
emotion saying i want to be part of a
sisterhood
but the reality is that not every
sorority is going to want this right
these are supposed to be unions of women
women
and there's not there's a lot of women
that aren't going to be comfortable in
that scenario where suddenly they're
supposed to be about solidarity of women
and you have a biological male that
enters the scene you're going to have a
lot of parents that aren't going to be
comfortable knowing
how these sororities interact how they
live on the same houses oftentimes how
they're housed they're very close
they're out you know there's sometimes
drinking involved even when it's not
supposed to be you know what the
sorority scene looks like i wasn't part
of it but
many of you out there do know
and there will be individuals um parents
students who aren't comfortable with
this dynamic now
there are a lot of sororities i did some
research and i did some digging that do
allow for trans and non-binary
individuals
so if you were trans and non-binary and
wanted to be in a sorority if you were a
biological male who now identified as a
woman you could seek out those
particular sororities i don't know if
those exist at the university of alabama
i'm to assume they don't because i'm
pretty sure grant would have gone that
route otherwise but they do exist
and there is going to be increasing
pressure on these organizations to be
all-inclusive
now what will that do to the population
of students i don't know i think there
will be some students that choose not to
join a sorority as a result of that
i'm pretty sure there's going to be some
parents that say i don't want you doing
that as a result of that because of
concerns you have to just look at this
objectively and not emotionally
you have to look at it and say
these rejections are not personal
they're not making a decision that they
don't like grant
it's not about grant they're making a
decision that you have uh an
organization that caters to women
biological women
there's a lot of closeness there's a lot
of shared spaces that goes on there and
it's not appropriate in their opinion
for a biological male to be part of
those spaces so this can't become an
emotional argument and i think everyone
needs to step outside of their box and
just look at this and say okay
i could see why a parent a student would
potentially have a problem with this and
not want to be part of an organization
that had this fluidity of thought
what's interesting is that sykes is not
the first transgender student to be
rejected from greek life i don't know if
you heard the story but this um adam
davies
was rejected from all 12 sororities at
northwestern university that story in
particular is very interesting to me
because adam was born a female
but identified as a male
and wanted to join a sorority so i'm
thinking what's going on there
why
if you're born a female and now
identifying as a male which leads me to
believe that you want to be treated as a
male
why do you want to be in a female
sorority i don't know there's just all
sorts of confusion i read a few articles
and adam was saying well it's more
complex than i mean at what point does
it just become does nothing need
anything and everyone just wants to be
part of anything and now it's like what
what
what boundaries are people trying to
push here is my question
people talk to me when i talk about this
about title uh ix
that was brought to my attention a few
times title ix prohibits sex
discrimination in education
title ix does not affect sororities and
fraternities the federal government has
made it so that sororities and
fraternities can make their own rules
when it comes to this stuff so it's up
to them now do you think there's going
to be a slippery slope here a hundred
percent this is not going to last very
long
these organizations will be labeled as
bigoted um they will be labeled i
already saw on grant's page i went to
grant's instagram and saw a number of
people with blue check marks who were
saying keep doing what you're doing
you're doing what's right people will
come around two-bit i saw the comments
and
i understand again watching this video i
can say this is someone who i do believe
is sincere i don't think was
ill-intentioned
i don't think based on what i see today
is looking to cause trouble or damage in
any way
but just step inside the shoes of those
biological females in that organization
you know step inside the lives of those
females who play on sports teams step
inside the lives of women who have to
exist in those locker rooms with
biological men
and even though you may not be maybe
you're out there and you don't intend to
harm
fine what if somebody does
what if it's just awkward that dynamic
what if it prevents women from wanting
to be involved in sports or what if it
just becomes an unsafe feeling space
because it's odd right it is odd why
were you separated always into the boys
and the girls because it's odd to have
it intermixed when people are taking
clothes off you catch a glimpse of this
she kept like you know how it goes
so people are uncomfortable
and hear why they're uncomfortable
listen and be able to have that
conversation with them in the same way
that it's expected that we have the
conversation with people who are trans
who want access to these communities i
do think there's going to be increased
pressure i think it's going to be forced
by public pressure soon and i think
you're going to have very few sororities
and fraternities that don't cave to this
you know within a very short period of
time if you like the short clip you can
catch another one here or you can catch
the full episode right here
[Music]